it is great to welcome to the program
today anthony scaramucci who is the
former white house communications
director
one of one of a few for the current
president uh also the founder
of sky bridge anthony i really
appreciate your time
it's good to be here david thank you for
having me so to start with
how did you first enter the universe of
donald trump
that that even led to you being in the
position of communications director
so i i just uh interviewed governor jeb
bush for my salt talk series and i
yelled at him
and told me see if you had won the
primary and gone on to the presidency i
wouldn't have been anywhere near the
white house and so
i'm your garden variety fundraiser i
happen to be hosting wall street week
for the fox business channel
in 2016. uh but i've been a lifelong
republican fundraiser i grew up in a
blue collar family so it was a way for
me to
reach a group of people that i would
have never had the opportunity to reach
through the networking of political
fundraising and so
uh i was working for jeb bush he dropped
out of the race looked like
then candidate trump was going to be the
nominee he called to recruit me
i went over to see him i had known him
from you know circles inside of new york
did i know him well know
but i knew him well enough where we had
a wrong you know rapport with each other
uh we had worked together on the 2012
mitt romney campaign where he had done
some fundraising
for governor romney and so i accepted
the
opportunity to go work for him steven
mnuchin and i built out the architecture
for his fundraising
and then when he won i was originally
supposed to be his opl director but then
reince priebus and steve bannon didn't
want me in the white house so they
pulled sort of a washington two-step i
then called president trump and this is
one of the classic mistakes and it's a
good learning lesson for your
listeners don't put your pride in your
ego into your decision making because
when you do that
your intelligence goes uh
down and your emotions go up and so i
made that mistake i told president trump
those two guys were bad guys
if you need me to help you get rid of
them call me one day i'll come down and
fix it for you next thing you know i'm
the comms director
uh i make a mistake i say something off
color which was actually ridiculously
funny about steve bannon
i thought i was saying it to a friend it
turned out the guy was a treacherous guy
and he ran over to cnn with a recording
of it
i got fired and frankly i deserve to be
fired i shouldn't have put the president
or the administration in that situation
but here's the silver lining i got out
of the white house i went back and
rebuilt my business
i saved my marriage and i created a
terrific relationship with
general kelly the man that fired me so
when you're having
ups and downs in life just got to keep
going as winston churchill said
when you're walking through hell keep
walking
so okay there's a bunch of things there
i wanted to touch base
about so one is you mentioned bannon
didn't want you
involved in the white house uh within if
i recall the timeline correctly
when you were announced as white house
comms director
sean spicer the timing of sean spicer
leaving
seemed to coincide with that it seemed
he didn't want you involved as well
because of it
what what is it why is it that these
guys did not want you involved
well i would say in fairness to steve at
that point i think he was indifferent i
don't think he cared if i was involved
or not it was really
reince priebus reince priebus really
didn't want anybody from new york
that had a rapport with president trump
to
be involved so that would have included
chris christie and mayor giuliani
as well as myself and other new yorkers
so uh
he had an unholy alliance it was an
unnatural alliance because these guys
really didn't like each other
but he had an oil alliance with steve
bannon
and so that's why if you remember this
is going back three years ago now there
was tremendous leaking and
tremendous amounts of dysfunctionality
in the white house
and so the president in fairness to the
president he deserved a better staff
than that he deserved people that were
going to try to help him execute his
agenda
but then we learned about the president
that he's not really a great manager so
he can't keep staff
or he has a tendency to rotate through
the staff too quickly there's no
loyalties or allegiances and this is why
you have this
unbelievably dysfunctional situation
that's unfolded for
the united states over the last four
years what ultimately caused
donald trump to turn on you so publicly
because if i recall correctly for a
little while after you left
at least it didn't seem like you were
being antagonized by the president but
at some point something changed there
well i mean i would say not only not
antagonized i was very supportive i i
left the white house i admitted that i
had made a mistake
i didn't blame anybody for my firing
other than myself and i was trying to
maintain a level of support and loyalty
that the president the republican party
and his agenda
uh and but you know listen i'm running a
business i've got to be objective he's
separating women from children
uh and putting them in cages i'm sorry i
can't subscribe to that
he's disavowing our intelligence
agencies in helsinki
can't subscribe to that he's calling the
press
the enemy of the people i mean it's in
the first amendment david for a reason i
can't subscribe to that i actually wrote
an op-ed
in april 2019 explaining why the press
is not the enemy of the people
uh but i think the peace the resistance
for me was the
uh he went after the four women in the
congress the
known as the squad uh some of them are
african americans one is a muslim
american
one is a hispanic american he said that
they should go back to the countries
that they originally came from three of
them were born in the u.s
one was a naturalized citizen all four
were democratically elected to our
congress that's a ridiculous racist
nativist trope and frankly david
they used to say that to my
italian-american grandparents 100 years
ago to go back to the country
that they originally came from and as i
told mayor giuliani i'm not going to
disavow
my personal integrity i'm not going to
disavow my family's
history in the united states by
supporting that kind of behavior so
i was on the bill more show i was trying
to defend him on the economy and some of
the
policies and deregulation i'm asked
about that i said no that's racism he
should not do that
so then he started to attack me that's
no problem i'm a big boy if you want to
attack me i'm a public figure i know how
to handle myself i attacked him back
i think i called him fidel ate off trump
i tried to get the fat shaming in there
you know
the notorious f.a.t with the
dictatorship
that he's trying to run he didn't like
that he hit me again so i hit him
and then he did what he classically does
because he's a complete low life he
starts going after my wife
and so listen my wife and i had personal
problems we almost got divorced as a
result of me
working for him i mean i mean she
dislikes them she probably doesn't
dislike him as much as melania trump
dislikes him but i mean she's up there
and so you know what what can i tell you
uh he goes after my wife
i mean now we're in a blood now we're in
a cage match yeah
you know i'm not ted cruz uh i'm an
italian kid from long island
uh you don't go after my wife and so the
fight started
uh and uh i don't want to see november
the third will be an interesting
referendum for the country and for mr
trump we'll have to see what happens but
i think he's going to get destroyed in
that election so help me understand
when you're although it was not a long
time but when you were in the role of
white house communications director from
the outside looking in
we see the constant lying from donald
trump and then we see people who are
brought in
who never will say it was a lie they
have to sort of clean it up we see it
with kaylee mcinanny
we've seen it with others what is going
on behind the scenes
in terms of are you all amongst
yourselves saying
this guy's lying how do we clean it up
or is there while people are in the role
you kind of put on a veneer where you
don't even admit to yourself that you're
defending lies
well i wasn't there long enough and i
only did one press conference and you
could go back and look at the press
conference i didn't lie at all in the
press conference in fact no no i mean
and to clarify i mean like observing
what it's like
when he's constantly lying in public and
people have to clean it up
well well yeah i mean that's there's
great frustration related to that i mean
i was only there for 11 days but i can
tell you we were preparing a speech he
steps into the rose garden
it's actually a very good number form i
don't remember exactly what it was about
but the number
was uh 86 he goes into the rose guard
and he says it's 90
it comes back into the oval office so
why did you say it was
90 i mean 86 was a great number no i
said 90 90 is a better number
well actually it actually isn't because
now you're gonna get four pinocchios on
the washington post and
it's going to add to this litany of lies
it doesn't it's not a good reflection on
you
you know he's making he doesn't come his
point is he's been lying in real estate
he's been lying in business he's been
lying to his wives he's been lying to
his children and
and so his point is i've gotten away
with this for so long
let me double and triple down on the lie
and if you
you know if you really study propaganda
you know what does joseph goebbel
say about the lie the bigger the lie
the more astounding it is the more you
can get people to believe it and so he's
got a group of willing acolytes
that will accept what he is saying even
though you can prove to them that it's a
lie
they'll accept what he's saying and so
for that
and so many other reasons he's got to go
and we're working super hard to make
that happen
so yesterday there was an article in
vanity fair by gabriel sherman
where it gabriel says that don jr in
particular
is very worried about the last 48 hours
worried about the corona caravan around
walter reed worried about the tweets
and that he doesn't want to be the only
one to go in and confront donald trump
and say this has to stop my question is
are are people afraid of those
confrontations because when you hear
trump say the 1917 flu for six months
it's like does nobody go in and say it's
1918 when he says
plasma instead of plasma for six months
is that because people are afraid to go
in and say
you know mr president you're saying this
wrong this is not right
well i mean you know they may say it to
him he'll either ignore it or they may
just not say it to him because they
don't want to get fired you know what
he's done
in october of 2019 someone came to my
office at sky bridge
a senior cabinet official a recognizable
name globally
sat on my couch and said hey you know
this is going to be really bad i said
well why is that well you know he can't
manage anything
and he's got everybody inside the
executive branch uh
fearing that they're going to be
humiliated on twitter or he's going to
fire them in this public display of
humiliation
and so they're not doing anything
they're all holding back and they're not
coordinating with each other and so you
need treasury sometimes to help justice
and
justice sometimes to help the department
of homeland security or the pentagon
to help state and everybody's frozen
there's
no mechanisms inside the white house or
at the cabinet level
that's creating a symphony of
communication among these
departments and cabinet agents
sub-agencies and so forth and so
if there is a crisis we will be
immobilized at the top of the government
we won't be able to handle the crisis i
actually thought the crisis was the
solemnity strike when that happened in
january which now seems like a thousand
years ago
i was looking at that thinking of what
that senior cabinet official said to me
in my office i said oh my god
this is going to be it thankfully cooler
has prevailed there
but it turned out the real crisis was
covered 19 he
was not capable of handling it he lives
in this reality distortion field
he's trying to force the people around
him to live in that distortion field
which is why
so many good people have left the
administration or been fired by him
because they won't
abide by his nonsense and so uh he's now
he's now there with a group of spineless
sycophants inside the white house
and he's lying through his teeth he lied
about the signs he lied about mass
wearing he couldn't coordinate a
unified strategy with the states to
bring down the virus and so the great
irony is
uh the economy which was the cornerstone
of his re-election campaign because of
his malfeasance and his malpractice
and his poor decision making he
destroyed the economy and so
we're sitting here right now we've got a
guy who's incompetent
we have a guy that is uh over
compensating for something
uh we got a guy that looked like he was
in a satire it was almost like a sacha
baron cohen satire comedy yesterday
of an eastern european dictator trying
to create a propaganda film
and that's where we are right now in
america but you know cnn's saying
5741 joe biden wall street journal
nbc saying 54 you know 42
joe biden maybe those polls are over
sample for democrats i don't know
i don't trust the polling any more than
anybody should
trust the polling we have to run through
the tape here and beat him on election
day so hopefully we'll do that
i think the good news i'm sorry well
he's the just the last statement the
good news for the american people he's
the polarizing candidate this time
people will go out and vote against him
when uh
when we look back at video of the
president speaking publicly over the
last several years
there seem to be sort of like two
different trumps that sometimes show up
there there's
what sometimes people would refer to as
upper trump the dilated pupils sweating
speaking very fast etc
sometimes there's what looks kind of
like a depressed trump
uh speaking slowly etc it a lot of
speculation about this
to your knowledge does donald trump use
or abuse
prescription or non-prescription or any
kind of
substances of any kind i i've never seen
that you know there's a few people on
the internet noelle casler that says he
has
uh seen that and so i'll take him at his
word for that knows he's
a good guy met him i have never seen it
and that's not me
saying he doesn't do it i just don't i
don't know it firsthand if he's done it
or not
if you ask me a different question if
you said observationally does he look
like he does
stuff like that the answer is yes but i
have never seen it personally so
it's not something i want to accuse him
of um when you
were uh at some point previously i don't
have the exact note in front of me but
you you've maintained
that donald trump is a smart person but
may have an
undetected learning disability
can you talk a little bit about the ways
in which you see him as smart
well let me stipulate this and something
bill clinton said many years ago
if you make it to the american
presidency prima facie you're smart it's
just like if you're
if you're a super bowl winning
quarterback well guess what you're a
good quarterback you know you're in a
top tier
league and so uh you know he has very
good political instincts
uh he probably has an undiagnosed
learning disability has difficulty
reading
and so what you find from people that
have adhd or learning disabilities they
assimilate information differently and
so if i'm blind i can hear better
but if i'm deaf perhaps i can see better
and so you have accentuated
other faculties i think he's pretty good
at
reading the situation i think he's
pretty good
in terms of optics of a situation he's a
boastful communicator so there's a lot
of over compensation
as a result of his deficits which led
him to the presidency
but unfortunately unlike richard branson
that has these issues who has a lot of
self-confidence and therefore can manage
things
mr trump has no self-confidence he has a
uh
a weird insecurity you would say jesus
somebody that's been so
successful somebody that has gotten to
be the american president you would you
would think that they would be more
secure of themselves but he's actually
not
and so a result of which he can't be in
the presence of super smart people
uh it creates a lot of self-loathing in
him and then he starts to pick on those
people
and dismantle those people he's a modern
day inca
david he believes in human sacrifice of
the professional kind so he'll take
somebody like rex tillerson
you'll see how talented he is he's oh my
god let me throw him in the volcano of
my
own personal self-hatred and so
ultimately he is the modern lbj his
self-loathing
and his lack of discipline uh and his
abstinence is going to lead to his
demise and so he's in a quagmire
that he doesn't have the skill or the
personal dexterity or the flexibility
to get out of and you know if you can
never admit you're wrong if you can
never change
course direction then ultimately
through your own ridiculousness you
paint yourself into a corner
that you can't get out of last thing i
want to touch on
if donald trump were to lose in november
there has been all sorts of speculation
of he will try not to leave in this way
he will try not to leave in that way the
military might have to step in he's
going to use the court so on and so
forth
what is actually the most likely path
forward for his behavior
if indeed he loses in november because i
think there's a there's the possibility
that something very different happens
which is
he just disappears yeah well i'm in
europe i'm in the disappearing camp and
i think
there's always a tell with donald trump
so
you know you you've never lived david
until the
president of the united states is
calling you an unstable nut job on
twitter which he's called me i mean
there's no there's no living like that
uh but
but you know that's projection he's the
unstable nut job you know so when you
find his
criticisms of others you can see the
self-hatred in himself and so he
projected
a tell about two weeks ago at one of his
rallies if i
quote unquote lose to this guy right
you'll never see or hear from me again
and i believe that
and so he'll be trounced he's just
saying all that disinformation and all
that stuff to try to
uh dispel people from voting he's a
almost he's he it's copyright by russian
active measures and russian kgb the it's
almost
you believe that you believe that's
what's going on
uh he's a useful idiot i don't
necessarily think he
is a agent for the kgb but if you look
at his twitter feed or you look at some
of his shenanigans related to the
sanctity of our electoral process
that's right out of vladimir putin's
playbook i mean it's right out of what a
kgb person would say
go look at his twitter feed it looks
like it was copy written
by the gru the special forces unit
inside of russia
that's all about propaganda so look this
is a complete
anomaly for the country we elected a
demagogue
uh we thought we were getting a seasoned
business person who was going to do some
disruptive things and
possibly be a post-partisan president
but we got a red tribal leader that's in
a great culture war
that doesn't have the intellectual
curiosity to
do the job properly and
you know he's lied about the science so
he got caught
where unfortunately on his watch there
was a global crisis that he was not
capable of handling
and i hope that'll that'll cause the end
of him meaning
he will leave and he will leave
unceremoniously
but to your point he will slink away and
just disappear
trust me if he loses 57
41 he's not starting his own network or
perpetuating
the reality ban show or the reality
rallies around the country he'll have no
standing
politically and it'll be an
embarrassment to him we will know very
soon we've been speaking with anthony
scaramucci who's former white house
communications director also the founder
of sky bridge
really do appreciate your time today
good to be here david good luck let's
talk again after the election